Speaker 1: All right. I know there's been a lot of
Alex Jones stuff on today's program, but it really
is an incredible situation now, as if things
aren't already looking bad enough for Infowars
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones after getting
caught lying yesterday in court and all of these
other things. We are now learning that as a result
of what has come out in the defamation trial, the
January six committee is planning to subpoena Alex
Jones. This is an exclusive from Rolling Stone.
January six Committee Prepares to Subpoena Alex
Jones Texts and emails. Jones Lawyers in a Sandy
Hook defamation case fumbled three years worth of
texts and emails. The committee would like to know
more about any contacts with Donald Trump's team
regarding the January 6th Capitol attack. This is.
Oh, and I'm not logged in and we're not
even going to deal with that right now.
I have another article about this January 6th
panel set to subpoena Alex Jones after revelations
in defamation trial. The January six Select
Committee is reportedly planning to subpoena
far right conspiracy theorist Alex Jones after
his texts and emails were revealed Wednesday
in a defamation lawsuit filed by Sandy Hook
shooting victim families in a cross-examination.
Sandy Hook victims attorney Mark Bankston told
Jones his lawyer erroneously sent Bankston three
years worth worth of the conspiracy theorists
emails and text messages copied from his
phone. The January six Select Committee is now
reportedly preparing to request those records
from the attorneys representing the Sandy
Hook victims to investigate the deadly Capitol
insurrection. This is just unbelievable,
going from bad to worse for Alex Jones.
And Jones has managed to keep himself more or
less isolated from the January six committee probe
that appears to be ending at this point in
time. And it would not shock me. I mean,
listen, at this point, I'm glad all of
this is happening. This it genuinely,
genuinely seems like this is what Alex Jones
deserves if we want to talk about about merit. But
Alex Jones must be considering do I fire my
attorneys? Do I have grounds for appeal later
based on improper or incompetent representation by
counsel? Because this is just going wrong for him
in absolutely every sense of the word. And there
are. It is not completely implausible that this
could be the end of Infowars. Now, if that's
the case, I'm not going to take pleasure in it
from a personal perspective, but I do think it's
important to be able to have a conversation about
is this entity a net positive or a net negative
for the world and for society? And there's a
real question about that. To put it lightly, to
understate it when it comes to Infowars. So we're
going to be watching all of this. Let's hope that
the January six committee does get those texts.
Why? Well, because we should know to what degree
Alex Jones was coordinating with people in Trump's
circle. So that's the latest there. And we'll
do one more Alex Jones thing before we move on.